last time we spoke was at Joffrey's wedding
miserable affair had its moments you believed
her she has something to live for now I
used to think you were the cleverest man
alive so you're the man I'm which man
am i you create the one who saved said
you're aware no one else could they
could they just wouldn't lose don't
be allowed home again now that my brother's
little your brother stood with your father
you fooled me more than anybody what
she never told you you always knew
exactly what she was we loved
her anyway I won't fight too
[Music] that's good to hear I'm going to
be encrypt with my son and I'd feel a lot
better when you down there to protect us
sure a lot of people would I'll write old
encrypt sent but whoremongering is still an
option for you things would be easier if it
were the perils of self-betterment in the
name of the warrior a charger to be brave
the name of the Father I charge you to be just
the name of the mother I charge you to
defend the innocent arise Brienne of Tarth
a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
high in the halls of the Kings
who are gone Jenny would dance with
her goes the one she had lost and
the ones she had found and the ones
who had loved her the moon [Music]
you know they give me to die again
if I got hurt probably if it weren't
for you I never would have survived my childhood
you were the only one we didn't treat
me like a monster you were all I had
hmm
[Music] obey your queen segreto
that's what you've always been
[Music]